well,
how is cristian cásseres doing with
his news now radio station in
spanish two people in las vegas' have
been arrested in connection with the takeover
of the capitol a few weeks ago these
two arrests in the valley are the most
recent of the 130 arrested  that
have already been carried out throughout the country
accused of participating along with hundreds
of protesters who
violently attacked the capitol in the usa
on january 6 the operation in las
vegas' was carried out by
federal agents and the metro police our
team of  investigators traced
legal documents and discovered the
identity of one of the arrested
investigators identified antonio del
grave from las vegas who appears in
these images wearing a red
white and blue bandana and equipped with
military tools among the
documents it is known that it was an
anonymous tip that has  dear investigators to
collect more evidence against tecos
bueno beneficiaries of the daca program
are in fr  2 of a possible change
in your immigration status after a
recent tweet the president of the usa
show park in recently published that
the trimmers are americans and i want them
to remember that they have an ally in me
within the white house so take
immediate action  to strengthen daca the
president immediately protected the
federal program through an
executive order during his first day as
president in which he promised to protect
the more than 64,000 young immigrants
who are in danger of being deported
the nevada local organization
affirms that there are more  of 14,000
beneficiaries of the program in the state
of nevada and efforts continue to
raise awareness in the community in the state
of nevada is surpassing the
vaccination effort against cob and 19 according to a
bloomberg analysis shows that
nevada is ranked 47th
among  other states this is up
from the 50th place we were
at at the start of the week plus
6.3 percent of all
nevada residents have already received their first
vaccine but we are still below the
national level
were one of the reasons why the cob vaccine has
been slow to distribute
and 19 is the lack of
reserves due to  As part of the federal government,
our team of researchers
discovered that Clark County is
scheduled to receive 42 doses a
week in addition to revealing that the county
can administer 92,000 vaccines per
week at that rate, the
entire Clark County resident could
still be vaccinated.  With the first dose in 20 weeks,
but the more doses of vaccines arrive in
the valley, the time to vaccinate
residents will decrease and after the
Knights rescheduled the game against
San Luis due to the coronavirus, the
National Hockey League warned that the player
Álex Pepper iced  along with a member of
the coaching team were under the
protocols of the coronavirus the announcement
was made at 10 that it was revealed that all
the coaches were under self
quarantine for now the
training facility has been closed and
all scheduled team games are being updated
finally we
take a look at the temperatures
an atmospheric system continues to ravage
across california that is
creating snow and rain for that  region the
same system that will bring light rains
for us and snow for the mountains
the temperatures will continue cold and
tonight they will drop to 50 I am cristian
cásseres with his previous informative
news now in Spanish happy Friday
[Music]